bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
de suivre la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi sur la modernisation du système
de santé hier soir les sénateurs ont
examiné l'article 2 qui vise à soutenir
les jeunes pour l'égalité des chances en
matière de santé en clair il est proposé
d'assouplir les conditions d'accès des
élèves du second degré à la
contraception d'urgence mais aussi de
renforcer la lutte contre la
consommation d'alcool
les sénateurs ont également examiné
toute la partie qui concerne les soins
palliatifs
voilà tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle à
869 rectifié qui est présentée
par monsieur riquet mais rien sur la
mamie du cher collègue dans le cadre du
rapport sur la proposition de loi sur la
création de nouveaux droits en faveur
des malades les personnes en fin de vie
et au cours des auditions les rapports
ont reçu auditionné un grand nombre de
professionnels ou acteurs associatifs
qui hantent eu de cesse de déplorer la
grande misère des soins palliatifs dont
l'accès est faible la distinction de la
coordination de ses soins et l enjeu
majeur de la modernisation de la
médecine qui doit en plus des soins
curatifs s'efforcer de prendre en charge
la douleur tout au long du suivi du
patient et ce notamment grâce aux soins
palliatifs qui est donc essentiel de
distinguer ces deux types de soins
la définition de la politique de santé
je suis ok maintenant
oui comme vous le dites chers collègues
cet amendement vise à préciser que
l'accès aux soins permis par la
politique de santé concerne à la fois le
volet curatif et le volet palliatifs
lors de l'élaboration de son texte la
commission estimé que cette précision
n'était pas nécessaire à cet endroit du
code qui énonce les objectifs de la
politique de santé en termes généraux et
dans la mesure où la proposition de loi
créant de nouveaux droits pour les
personnes en fin de vie entend modifier
d'autres articles du code pour renforcer
la vocation palliatifs de la médecine
c'est donc un avis de défaut râble qui a
été mis par la commission simone
important madame la ministre
oui je vais donner un avis défavorable à
cet amendement
alors même que dans le cadre de la mise
en place d'une prise en charge de la fin
de vie il faut évidemment faire en sorte
que les soins palliatifs soit développée
mais dans le cadre de cette loi les
soins englobe toute une série de soins
différents il ya les soins palliatifs ya
des soins currin curatif il peut y avoir
des soins à ce moment là on peut rentrer
dans la catégorisation et des sous
catégories de soins des soins
reconstructeurs réparateur on peut
imaginer toute une série de deux sous
catégories qui sont justifiés prises
indépendamment les unes des autres mais
qui sont englobés dans l'idée de soins
au niveau d'une définition générale de
l'objectif du politique de santé c'est
pour cela que j'en ai un avis
défavorable à votre amendement non pas
par défiance à l'égard de l'idée de soin
palliatif et parce que à entrer trop
dans les détails on finit par
s'interroger sur ce qui n'est pas
explicitement mentionné et ce qui n'est
pas explicitement mentionné à ce moment
là semble ne plus faire partie de la loi
donc avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre je le bo voici 869 rectifier à
pardon monsieur le président de
commission
sans vouloir revenir sur quoi que ce
soit mais à partir du moment où on parle
de soins la cdu global alors que tout à
l'heure on parlait de santé il fallait
aller dans le détail je veux dire que
clairement je suis un petit peu perturbé
moi aussi monsieur d'audignies mais
devint sens inverse et quand on parle de
santé on parle de santé en global
également quand on parle de soi on parle
de soins en global également ou alors on
va dans le détail dans la santé quand
nous y a
incité tout à l'heure en allant jusque
dans les pratiques sportives on n'est
pas allé jusqu'à jusqu'au reste
heureusement mais là puisqu'on est aux
soins et qu'on va dans le détail
pourquoi pas je dire quelque part il
faut être cohérent et la cohérence pour
moi n'existe plus
le président
y at il d'autres explications de vote
monsieur roquet
il est retiré
1 689 qui est présenté par madame cohen
pour moi cet amendement tome puisque
nous avons adopté tout à l'heure à
l'alinéa 4 la notion d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes j'avais juste
pointé que peut-être c'était pas au bon
endroit mais que de toute façon nous ne
votions de bon coeur
madame cohen
le 690 madame david
oui merci monsieur le président cet
amendement est en réalité la
réintroduction de la linea 13 du projet
de loi tel qu'il a été adopté à
l'assemblée nationale et je tiens à
rappeler ici que nous avons eu
l'occasion de débattre en première
lecture au mois de mai du projet de loi
l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement mais le texte
initialement consacrée à la perte
d'autonomie et à tous les âges de la vie
a finalement été réduit à la perte
d'autonomie des personnes vieillissantes
et donc cet alinéa 13 dans le projet
adopté à l'assemblée nationale était
pour nous un bon signal c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous le réintroduisant
puisque la commission la supprimer en
effet on estime en france à sept cent
mille le nombre de personnes handicapées
et à 600 mille le nombre de personnes
invalides que prévoit le texte de la
commission pour leur permettre de vivre
le plus longtemps chez elle de pouvoir
décider de leur vie réaliser leurs
projets travailler se soigner je suis au
regret de dire mesdames les rapporteurs
et monsieur le rapporteur que le texte
ne prévoit rien nous estimons pour notre
part que seule la solidarité de la
société est à même de prendre en charge
ces défis et dès lors il est nécessaire
d'affirmer dans ce projet de loi de
modernisation de la santé comme cela a
été fait à l'assemblée nationale que la
stratégie nationale de santé
en charge de manière collective et
solidaire les personnes accidentées et
handicapées merci madame david madame le
rapporteur
alors il nous a semblé en commission que
effectivement ce champ ne relevait pas à
proprement parler de la politique de
santé mais plutôt du code de la sécurité
sociale et de l'organisation de notre
système de protection sociale et
d'ailleurs quand on lit les termes de
votre proposition on entend bien cette
charge collective et solidaire des
conséquences financières et sociales de
la maladie et c'est pour cette raison
que la commission des affaires sociales
a émis un avis défavorable
merci mesdames la porte on me donne le
ministre je tenais un avis favorable à
ces amendements parce que le caractère
de solidarité de la prise en charge de
la politique de santé et de la politique
de santé elle même est un élément
constitutif de notre organisation donc
avis favorable si madame la ministre je
le mets aux voix avec un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté un
amendement 78 édifié monsieur cohen
se présente à manama monsieur le
président la ministre vise à faire
reconnaître l'applicabilité de l'article
6 1 de la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme aux droits des usagers
du système de santé le premier enjeu de
cette reconnaissance réside notamment
dans l'obligation pour le système de
santé national de permettre l'accès à ce
droit de manière impartiale et en un
délai raisonnable le second cas je tiens
rend possible l'invocation devant toute
juridiction compétente pour connaître un
litige afférents des garanties
processuel prévues par le texte
conventionnel
merci monsieur commeinhes madame la
rapporteure
alors chers collègues cet amendement
nous a posé quelques problèmes de
compréhension et donc nous avons émis un
avis défavorable
si madame le ministre
oui avis défavorable aussi
parce que je ne suis pas certaine de
voir
quelle est la portée de la référence à
l'article 6 de la cdh dans ce contexte
là je vous demanderais plutôt de retirer
votre amendement sinon un avis
défavorable parce que ils s'insèrent
vraiment très très mal dans le texte
quel que soit le texte de référence la
ministre vous le maintenez vous le
retirer merci monsieur comme n2
amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune 1 188 rectifier si
monsieur barbier qui défend
jeu je retire cet amendement profit de
l'amendement suivante monsieur barbier
donc le 188 rectifier et retirer le 881
rectifié monsieur ruquier
exercice est comme moi
cher foulée samba vous dire que d'hommes
nous a offert une série de deux
collectivités et de projets elle a
consulté pour mater le santé et
simplement je prends la question savoir
si dans les genres et les collectivités
le territoriales il y avait donc les
élus locaux voilà merci monsieur recul
madame le rapporteur
alors que les élus locaux ne soient pas
spectateur c'est évidemment ce que nous
souhaitons partout non seulement dans la
politique de santé mais aussi la
politique des territoires il nous a
semblé que l'article l 14 11-1 du code
de la sécurité sociale que le présent
amendement entend compléter n'a pas
vocation à énumérer l'ensemble des
organismes qui sont associés à la
concertation préalable à toute réforme
de la politique de santé il convient par
ailleurs de noter que la création d'une
organisation représentative des
associations des usagers ne semble pas
faire consensus chez ces associations
c'est ce qu'on a pu entendre au cours de
nos auditions pour cette double raison
la commission des affaires sociales n'a
pas jugé opportun de maintenir cette
disposition dans le texte transmis par
l'assemblée nationale c'est donc un avis
défavorable 15 me la commission des
affaires sociales qui me semble
important madame la ministre
si pour ma part j'ai un avis favorable à
cette
amendement
je pense que maintenant les choses sont
à peu près rodez semble-t-il dans notre
façon de nous répartir les avis mais
donc avis favorable je tiens d'ailleurs
à préciser que après des moments de
comment dire de nom consensus entre les
différents représentants des usagers ils
ont maintenant converger vers une
position consensuelle est favorable à la
rédaction du texte et il me semble
nécessaire il me semble utile plutôt de
marquer le rôle des collectivités
territoriales la même ministre je le
mets aux voix qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté un
amendement 858 mesdames archambault
le stick de certaines pathologies et
parfois rendue compliquée du fait de
spécificités propres à la personne qui
en est atteinte prendre en compte les
particularités du patient du fait de sa
situation sociale de ces pratiques ou de
son environnement est souvent un moyen
de pallier les difficultés du diagnostic
ainsi que d'y apporter les traitements
les mieux adopter c'est ce que cet
amendement propose ajouté à la
définition des objectifs de notre
politique de santé qui marche un beau
bonhomme le rapporteur
alors cette président précision n'a pas
sa place à l'article l 14 11-1-1 dans sa
rédaction issue des travaux de la
commission cet article concerne en effet
la procédure d'élaboration et de
révision de la politique de santé la
précision proposé nous apparaît en outre
posé un problème de redondance avec les
autres dispositions de l'article 1er
c'est donc un avis défavorable de la
commission
merci même reportera madame la ministre
je vous demanderais plutôt de retirer
cet amendement
parce que les facteurs dont vous
souhaitez la prise en compte sont
évoqués pour ce qui est ce qui relève de
la politique de santé là vous souhaitez
le réintroduire pour la stratégie
nationale de santé donc c'est un débat
entre de la relation entre la stratégie
nationale de santé la peau meetic de
santé la politique est plus vaste et la
stratégie nationale de santé est une
manière de décliner à un moment donné la
politique de santé donc puisque les
critères que vous évoquez sont pris en
compte dans la politique de santé ils le
sont nécessairement à un moment donné
dans une stratégie plus opérationnels
mouvement aurait bien de retirer votre
amour merci même la ministre madame
archambault il est retiré merci le 1116
rectifier c'est monsieur quand nano
qui le défend cet amendement
reprend les recommandations du rapport
de la cour des comptes du 12 juin 2014
intitulé la santé dans les outre-mers
nous responsabilité de la république tu
es mon cher collègue madame le
rapporteur
alors cet amendement nous semblent
satisfaits par le vote prochain de
l'article 1er bis et donc c'est une
demande de retrait qui vous est proposée
par la commission des affaires sociales
nommé rapporteur madame la ministre
un amendement va venir qui introduit
explicitement à l'article 1 bis qui
porte sur les questions que vous
soulevez relatives à l'outre-mer et donc
il me paraît souhaitable que vous
retiriez l'amendement que vous présentez
à l'instant merci madame la ministre
monsieur cornano est-ce que vous axez
d'aix demande
si c'est satisfait je le retire
il est retiré donc
le 691
me monsieur m oui le projet de loi
prévoit que les organisations
représentatives des professionnels de
santé les associations agréées concours
la mise en oeuvre de la politique de
santé dans le cadre de leurs compétences
le texte ne prévoit pas en revanche les
associer à la consultation préalable à
l'adoption et la révision des objectifs
et des priorités du projet de stratégie
nationale de santé il nous apparaît
pourtant nécessaire de les y associer
même si j'ai bien entendu ce que vient
de dire la ministre tout comme les
représentants des collectivités
territoriales et les représentants des
personnels chacun ayant une expérience
reconnue dans son domaine cet amendement
s'inscrit donc dans une démarche globale
qui consiste à redonner de la place aux
collectivités territoriales aux
professionnels de santé et aux
représentants du personnel ainsi qu aux
usagers dans les prises de décision
quelle qu'elle soit afin de tendre vers
une véritable démocratie sanitaire ici
il ya bien la notion de consultations
publiques mais elles mériteraient d'être
précisés tel est le sens de cette amende
merci monsieur latreille madame le
rapporteur
alors sans surprise parce que je l' ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises cet
article 14 11-1 n'a pas vocation à
énumérer l'ensemble des organismes ou
des partenaires à consulter avant que le
gouvernement adopte ou révise sa
stratégie nationale de santé c'est donc
un avis défavorable émis par la
commission si maintenant remporté ormes
dans le ministre il me semble monsieur
le sénateur que votre amendement est
satisfait d'ailleurs vous le soulignez
vous même vous préciser les acteurs qui
doivent être consultés et donc vous
prenez le risque d'écarter d'autres
acteurs qui pourrait être consulté ces
dispositions de concertation de
consultation sont importantes elles
donneront lieu à la rédaction d'un
décret enfin la publication d'un décret
qui est d'ailleurs en voie de
finalisation déjà pour pouvoir sortir
assez vite dès lors que la loi sera
votée donc je vous demande de retirer
votre amendement sinon je donne un avis
défavorable parce qu'il me semble à la
fois satisfait et plutôt restrictif et
donc
aboutissants un résultat à mon avis
contraire à celui que vous recherchez
merci même vu nice monsieur watrin
écoutez donc notre intention n'était pas
d'avoir une liste exclusive d'autres
personnes d'autres organismes ou
d'autres représentants associé à la
concertation nécessaire à la mise en
oeuvre et à la définition des politiques
de santé des priorités de santé donc si
vous madame la ministre nous dit à
l'instant que ce que l'on a cité mais
peut y avoir d'autres seront inclus dans
le décret et bien nécessaire qui
précisera les participants à la
consultation publique a aucune raison
que nous maintenions cet amendement donc
je remercie la ministre d'avoir pris en
compte notre proposition si monsieur
battre un
monsieur le président site merci
monsieur président juste pour ajouter
comme ça par taquineries certainement un
élément supplémentaire mais depuis le
début de la discussion de cette loi
c'est ce que les rapporteurs 10 plus on
met de détails dans la loi plus on
écarte ceux qui ne sont pas dans le
détail
le président le 479 rectifié bis c'est
madame génisson qui le défend monsieur
daudigny
479 rectifié bis monsieur d'audignies
je prends l'objet très simplement
l'amendement vise à compléter
initiatives institutionnelles d'accès à
la prévention et de promotion de la
santé ils tendent à favoriser des
actions de proximité et de prévention
partagé permettant une meilleure
implication et participation des publics
si dans le cadre de concertation et de
coordination de l'ensemble des
politiques publiques
je donnais ni madame le rapporteur
alors cet amendement précise le cadre de
réalisation des actions de promotion de
la santé après nos débats après vous
avoir entendu nous avons proposé donc la
sagesse de notre grande de notre haute
assemblée donc voilà comme quoi la
commission peut aussi avancer échangés
merci mme l'important madame la ministre
oui avis avis favorable merci madame la
ministre je le mets aux voix un bonhomme
génisson
l'explication de vote oui merci le
monsieur le président excusez moi de ne
pas avoir répondu à notre sollicitation
mais j'avais un amendement quasiment
similaire sous la main et pas celui ci
oui je pense que vraiment ce sujet de
prévention partager tout à fait
fondamental je crois que il ya tous les
acteurs institutionnels qu'il soit
médicaux médico-sociaux enfin les
professionnels qui sont très comment
dire engagée sur le sujet de la
prévention mais en ce qui concerne les
publics cibles et je pense en
particulier au public jeune et je pense
en particulier à la prêts à la lutte
contre le tabagisme beaucoup
d'expérience dans en france comme dans
d'autres pays ont montré qu'en que quand
les jeunes étaient acteurs eux-mêmes de
leurs messages de prévention et des
actions de prévention qu'il menait seul
a donné des résultats beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus importants dès lors que
les acteurs étaient responsabiliser donc
cette notion de de prévention au partage
est tout à fait fondamental est
intéressante à introduire dans la loi et
merci à la fois à même la rapporteure et
madame la ministre d'accepter cet
amendement merci madame génisson je le
mets aux voix qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté le 40 rectifié bis monsieur
commeinhes
tous les acteurs de santé contribuent à
la politique de santé la démocratie
sanitaire est un élément essentiel de
nature à permettre à l'ensemble des
acteurs du système de santé de
s'impliquer dans l'élaboration et la
mise en oeuvre de la politique de santé
il contribue à sa vitalité en organisant
leur représentation des associations
d'usagers agréé la démocratie sanitaire
constitue aussi un facteur de
développement d'une réponse adaptée aux
besoins de soins et contribuer avec
l'airé l'état dans le pilotage du
système de santé et la définition de sa
politique à cet effet fait revivre la
démocratie sanitaire implique de
développer la concertation et le débat
public
améliorer la participation acteurs de
santé des usagers du système de santé
dans la gouvernance du système à tous
les niveaux promouvoir les droits
individuels et collectifs des usagers la
démocratie sanitaire concerne l'ensemble
des acteurs parties prenantes du système
de santé les usagers comme
professionnels eux doit donc impliquer
les associations d'usagers à gré les
établissements de santé publics et
privés et les professions libérales du
secteur sanitaire et social
merci monsieur commun une madame le
rapporteur
votre attention chers collègues est
partagé par tous elle est partagée par
la commission des affaires sociales mais
comme je les dis à différentes reprises
nous ne pouvons pas commencer à citer
les différents intervenants ou
participants et pour cette raison j'ai
mettrait un avis défavorable à moi que
vous retiriez cet amendement
merci madame en porter
madame la ministre merci pour le lien
même avis
vous le retirez monsieur cobain vous le
maintenez
il est retiré vous pouvez donc
représenter le 41 rectifier ensuite
les établissements de santé publics et
privés sont soumis à des autorisations
sanitaire délivrés par les représentants
de l'état c'est donc sur l'ensemble de
ses acteurs que l'état s'appuie pour
mettre en oeuvre la politique de santé
qu'ils soient publics ou privés en
rappelant l'association de tous les
acteurs à la mise en oeuvre de la
politique de santé la loi renforce la
cohésion du système de santé favorise
l'efficacité de la réponse aux besoins
de santé de l'ensemble de la population
tout en garantissant la liberté de choix
qui caractérise notre système de santé
merci monsieur commun madame le
rapporteur
oui alors cet amendement prévoit
explicitement l'association des
établissements de santé et des
professionnels de santé libéraux à la
mise en oeuvre de la politique de santé
pour assurer l'équilibré recherché de
l'offre de soins sur les territoires
cette précision apparaît redondantes et
je vous renvoie aux alinéas 11 12 et 25
de l'article 1er cet article n'a pas par
ailleurs vocation à citer l'ensemble des
acteurs comme je le disais tout à
l'heure contribuant donc à la mise en
oeuvre de la politique de santé et la
commission des affaires sociales a émis
un avis défavorable
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre mais ma vie même avis je le
mets aux voix qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté un
amendement 870 rectifié qui est
présentée par monsieur arnel
cet amendement concerne les
problématiques de santé de l'enfant qui
sont évidemment trop souvent appréhendée
de manière détachée de son environnement
afin de pouvoir au mieux prendre en
charge la santé de l'enfant du nous
semble qu'il est essentiel de le faire
au travers d'une démarche globale qui
s'attache aussi à son entourage familial
madame le rapporteur
est là vous faites référence à la
politique de santé de l'enfant et de la
famille parmi les missions du haut
conseil de la santé publique
cet amendement entend donc préciser les
missions 1 de ce haut conseil définie à
l'article l 14 11-4 du code de la santé
publique en faisant une référence à la
politique de santé de l'enfant et de la
famille l'émission de ce haut conseil
sont définis en des termes généraux il
s'agit de en premier lieu contribuer à
l'élaboration et à l'évaluation de la
politique de santé de fournir aux
pouvoirs publics en liaison avec les
agences sanitaires les expertises
nécessaires à la gestion des risques
sanitaires ainsi qu'à la conception et à
l'évaluation des politiques et
stratégies de prévention et de sécurité
sanitaire et pour terminer de fournir
aux pouvoirs publics des réflexions
prospectives des conseils sur les
questions de santé publique
je tenais à préciser ces éléments parce
que les différents publics auxquels
s'adresse la politique de santé ne sont
pas énumérer dans cet article général
c'est la deuxième partie du code de la
santé publique qui rassemble l'ensemble
des dispositions relatives à la
politique de santé de la famille de la
mère et de l'enfant et donc c'est une
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable de la commission merci
madame le rapporteur me down on me et
bien pour ma part j'ai un avis favorable
à cet amendement qui propose de rétablir
la rédaction qui est sorti de
l'assemblée nationale et qui permet de
bien identifier en termes de santé
publique les enjeux liés aux enfants et
aux familles mais en particulier aux
enfants et c'est un des fils conducteurs
de la loi qui est présentée l'enfance la
jeunesse donc les familles puisque l'on
sait que les conditions de santé
s'élabore le plus souvent dans la petite
enfance merci madame la ministre je le
mets aux voix qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté
1,42 rectifié bis monsieur comme n
é il est retiré
madame la rapporteure t'es juste un
amendement de coordination merci madame
le rapporteur madame la ministre
favorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté à 1 945 qui présenté par madame
archambault
alors c'est un amendement qui vise à
garantir la place de la santé
environnementale au coeur de la
stratégie nationale de santé et à
l'application du troisième pns plan
national santé environnement
il s'agit en fait je voulais de
connecter entre les outils de nos
politiques de santé publique afin donc
que
la réflexion les outils qui sont mis à
la disposition de la santé
environnementale ne reste pas à côté de
la stratégie nationale de santé mais
soit vraiment intégré dans ce sera
gilles stratégie nationale de santé de
façon à ce que tout le travail qu'ils
effectuent est là
soit soit soient intégrés quoi que ce
soit pas que la skull que la santé
mentale ne soit pas considéré comme
l'ensemble dispositif à côté du reste
merci madame archambault madame le
rapport tord
cet objectif est évidemment louable mais
il nous semblait que ça relevait de la
responsabilité du ministre il appartient
en effet au gouvernement dans le cadre
de son action interministériel de
garantir cette cohérence dans la mise en
oeuvre de la stratégie nationale de
santé c'est donc un avis défavorable
madame la ministre
je donne un avis favorable à votre
amendement madame archambault parce que
la prise en compte de l'impact de
l'environnement sur la santé est
explicitement identifiés comme une des
composante essentielle de la stratégie
nationale de santé je ne reviens pas sur
ce que j'ai pu avoir l'occasion de dire
sur l'élaboration du plan national santé
environnement tous les cinq ans qui est
inscrite dans le code de la santé
publique ce qui montre bien que les
enjeux environnementaux sont désormais
pris en compte dans l'élaboration des
politiques
de santé et la stratégie nationale de
santé
je vous remercie madame la ministre je
vais le mettre aux voix avec un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis
favorable du gouvernement monsieur le
président
merci merci monsieur le président je
disais que je ne dois certainement pas
tout comprendre dans ce qui se passe ce
soir
seulement par un petit manque
d'intelligence et je m'en excuse auprès
de vous enfin tout à l'heure on a déjà
parlé d' exposé hommes
on a donc déjà parlé de l'exposition aux
différents problèmes environnementaux
on revient encore une fois dessus pour
en reparler à nouveau si vous voulez
tout à l'heure dans l'article 2 on en
reparlera à nouveau dans le iii aussi
dans le 4 et dans le deux sens également
et s'il faut parler à chaque fois de
l'exposition aux problèmes
environnementaux
moi je veux bien mais on l'a mis une
fois pourquoi leur mètre cinquante fois
vraiment cesse
bon si vous voulez ok la santé
environnementale en plus oui enfin bon
ça suffit quoi
merci monsieur le président madame
jouanno
si je peux être d'une quelconque aide
pour essayer de vous aider à clarifier
le débat et à comprendre la notion d'
exposé aux mené qu'une partie
effectivement des sujets qui sont
concernés par la santé environnementale
on a on est aujourd'hui au troisième
plan national de santé environnementale
et malheureusement il est vrai qu'on a
toujours un pse qui est à côté d'une
politique de santé publique et quelles
que soient les déclarations on a un
pénis avec des domaines extrêmement
ciblée et puis à côté on a une politique
de santé ou de santé publique qui semble
marcher de manière parallèle mais pas
toujours de manière très convergente
donc ce serait extrêmement intéressant
qu'on puisse clairement dire dans la loi
que la politique l'ap le plan national
de santé environnement et dans la
politique de santé publique et ne plus
avoir le sentiment quand on est et
secrétaires d'état à l'écologie que on
fait des petites choses dans notre coin
qu'on nous laisse jouer avec quelques
sujets mais que finalement les choses
sérieuses de la santé publique ça se
passe ailleurs
merci madame jouanno madame yonnais
juste rapidement vient d'être dit il
nous sommes entièrement d'accord avec
mes
je sais pas il me semble qu'une loi
c'est quand même un document qui est
opposable donc ça nous paraît quand même
important d'y apporter des amendements
et à ce que les choses soient marquées
d'une façon claire et précise justement
pour les opposer donc si l'article
premier n'avait pas été totalement
dénaturé dans sa nouvelle rédaction par
les membres de la commission
majoritaire je veux dire on n'en serait
pas à rajouter à chaque fois sur
l'article premier des amendements donc
étant donné qu'ils aient l'article
premier a été retiré de sa substance
initial effectivement on rajoute des
amendements qui ont été supprimés en
parle de la politique environnementale
comme de l'aide aux aidants et cetera du
handicap et tous
merci ma chère collègue monsieur le
président
merci monsieur président
surtout pour dire comme ça que la
majorité sénatoriale a dénaturé la loi
c'est faux nous avons voulu la
généraliser afin que tous puissent
rentrer à l'intérieur vous en y mettant
des détails vous oblige obligatoirement
un moment ou un autre c'est madame
jouanno elle même qui a dit qu'un exposé
hommes s'étaient c'était c'était un
petit une petite chose un détail donc on
a mis un détail quelque part aux mains
des tailles ailleurs on va en oublier on
va en oublier et au bout du compte cette
loi telle qu'elle sortira ne sera pas
n'aura pas un effet général tel qu'il
est souhaité par par la majorité
sénatoriale et puis puisqu'une en sommes
là et son pouvoir de donner de leçon à
personne je vous invite à relire la
lettre 79 de montesquieu
merci monsieur le président je mets donc
on voit cet amendement qui a reçu je le
rappelle un avis défavorable de la
commission et un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté 1 946
présenté par un machin beau
la comparaison avec le japon pays au
niveau de développement au système
d'assurance maladie similaire est
instructive selon le rapport de l' oms
sur les maladies non transmissibles
2011 le taux de maladies chroniques pour
cent mille personnes et de 419 pour la
france contre 337 au japon on peut en
déduire que si la france avait le même
taux de maladies non transmissibles que
le japon le nombre d'affections de
longue durée dont le coût global en 2008
est estimée à 79 milliards d'euros
serait diminué de 25% donc cet
amendement vise donc à fixer
dans la loi un objectif chiffré de
réduction de 25% du taux de maladies
chroniques à horizon 2030
notre objectif avec cette proposition
d'amendement c'est d'avoir un objectif
chiffré qui qui qui traduit cette
volonté qui s'est d'ailleurs exprimé
plusieurs fois ce soir dans les
amendements de vraiment réorienter les
politiques parent et forme pour qu'un
effort manifeste soit fait notamment sur
la sur la prévention primaire et cela
aurait également nous semble-t-il un
impact non négociables sur l' équilibre
de la caisse d'assurance maladie mais
aussi sur le mieux vivre nos concitoyens
par dans un impact non négligeable sur
l' équilibre de la caisse d'assurance
maladie mais aussi sur le mieux vivre de
nos concitoyens qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à être touchés eux mêmes ou par
dans le parmi les proches de leur
famille merci tu m'aimes archimbaud
madame le rapporteur pour la ville de
commissions on pourrait effectivement
partagé cette ambition de réduire
c'est ces maladies chroniques simplement
le fait de marquer un objectif chiffré
c'est d'ordre réglementaire et donc pour
cette raison
nous avons émis un avis défavorable
merci même le rapporteur madame la
ministre
je suis désolé madame la sénatrice mais
j'ai donné un avis défavorable
d'abord parce que si je faisais du
mauvais esprit on pourrait atteindre
l'objectif que vous fixez en faisant en
sorte que des perses en faisant en sorte
je ne suis pas sûr que nous puissions
poser là dessus mais en voyant là une
réduction de l'espérance de vie puisque
l'augmentation des maladies chroniques
tient aussi à l'allongement de la durée
de la vie donc si les gens vivaient
moins longtemps il y aurait moins de
maladies chroniques c'est quand même pas
l'objectif recherché mais de manière
plus sérieuse de manière plus sérieuse
d'une part il y aurait des difficultés
extraordinairement élevé pour mesurer la
réduction des maladies chroniques est ce
que c'est une maladie individuellement
les maladies associées les modes
d'évaluation donnerait lieu à des
travaux extrêmement long et puis à force
de fixer des objectifs chiffrés on ne se
donne pas les moyens
de mettre en place des politiques puis
qualitative et c'est très exactement ce
qui s'est passé avec la loi de 2004 qui
a prévu toute une série de plans de
santé publique avec des objectifs et à
l'arrivée on a une multiplication de
plans sans coordination sans
articulation qui ne donne pas naissance
qui n'ont pas donné naissance à une
véritable politique globale de santé
publique donc il faut qu'il puisse y
avoir des indicateurs au niveau
réglementaire pour les organismes
compétents que les organismes compétents
se fixe des objectifs à eux mêmes c'est
très bien on ne peut pas inscrire dans
la loi un objectif de telle nature
merci madame la ministre je le mets aux
voix
oui mesdames archambault pour
explication de vote
notre préoccupation demeure mais nous
allons
retirer cet amendement et essayer d'en
améliorer
la rédaction il ya manifestement elle
travaillait encore un peu plus tard très
bien madame archambault je vous remercie
il est donc retiré je vais mettre aux
voix l'article 1er ainsi modifié qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté après l'article 1er un
amendement
590 e rectifier il est retiré mais mme
jouanno à l'article 20 bis 1 692 qui est
présenté par madame david
oui merci monsieur le président cet
amendement je le présente donc au nom de
notre groupe et au nom de notre collègue
paul vergès sénateur de la réunion
ils demandent à ce que des données
statistiques fiables et pérennes enfin
puissent être prises en compte pour
cette politique de santé publique
dans les outre-mer en effet la cour des
comptes dans son rapport thématique
publié en juin 2014 intitulé la santé
dans les outre-mers une responsabilité
de la république affirme il n'existe pas
d'études statistiques exhaustives
retraçant les dépenses de santé
outre-mer et dans ce même rapport le mot
statistique est souvent accolé à ceux
d'un complète hétérogènes malaisément
comparable approximative inexistante
illusoire dans certains départements
comme mayotte ou encore la guyane ces
données sont partielles voire
inexistantes dans les collectivités
d'outre-mer les statistiques exhaustives
par exemple sur les densité médicale
font défaut un avis partagé par le
ministère de la santé qui en réponse au
rapport de la cour des comptes estime je
cite il convient d'être prudent sur la
fiabilité des données
statistiques se rapportant à l'outre-mer
en particulier s'agissant des
territoires autres que les dom ainsi que
par rapport à certaines comparaisons qui
paraissent comporter des billets mythe
méthodologique alors même si l'on peut
assister à quelques progrès il est
impossible d'évaluer l'impact des
politiques publiques menées localement
et de définir des objectifs
répondant aux caractéristiques et
réalité ultramarines c'est pour ces
raisons que je vous demande mes chers
collègues de voter cet amendement
et comme je le disais ce matin en
commission
c'est bien de statistiques fiables et
pérennes dont les départements
d'outre-mer ont besoin pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre cette politique de
santé publique
merci madame david madame le rapporteur
alors des statistiques fiables et
pérennes moi à titre personnel je n'ose
imaginer qu'elle puisse ce qu'elles ne
puissent pas être fiable et pérenne vous
me dit qu'effectivement
probablement il n'y a pas suffisamment
d'études sur l'outre-mer en même temps
l'article 1er bis dans son alinéa 2 dit
bien que c'est à partir d'une évaluation
des données épidémiologiques que la
stratégie nationale de santé sera adapté
aux territoires d'outre-mer et c'est
donc un avis défavorable que la
commission a émises et sinon le retirer
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre
oui je vous demanderais plutôt de
retirer votre amendement parce que
l'objectif ou le sujet de vous poser un
sujet réel mais va venir un peu plus
tard un amendement
827 qui me semble mieux rédigé pour qui
prévoit que toute statistique décliné au
niveau local comporte nécessairement les
données chiffrées contenant les
concernant pendant les collectivités
d'outre-mer donc
je crois que l'objectif que vous
recherchez sera atteint en s'inscrivant
dans une stratégie d'ensemble c'est pour
cela que je vous demande de bien vouloir
retirer votre amendement sinon je donne
un avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre madame david
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
remercier madame la ministre pour ces
informations et pour le fait de dire que
en effet la problématique soulevée par
cet amendement est réel
voilà madame la rapporteure peut-être
at-elle été distraite par le prêt des
présidents retailleau pendant que
j'expliquais la raison de cet amendement
et j'apprécie que madame la ministre
donne raison au contenu même de cet
amendement et si cet amendement 827 qui
sera présenté dans un instant en effet
donne satisfaction à cette préoccupation
nous sommes favorables à retirer cet
amendement bien merci il est donc on
retire et madame david il est retiré je
mets aux voix l'article 1 bis qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article 1 bis cinq
amendements identiques avec un sens être
rectifiées il est pas soutenu 1
il n'est pas soutenu 1
346 rectifier c'est madame loisier
si monsieur présidence cet amendement
s'attache à la situation des quelques 8
millions d'aidants non professionnels
qui jouent un rôle central dans l'aide
et l'accompagnement d'un proche il
préconise l'analyse des risques
psychosociaux qui pèsent sur les aidants
proches des études épidémiologiques sur
les pathologies et leurs coûts sociaux
qui doivent être menées pour mettre en
place une réelle politique de santé une
stratégie nationale efficace en matière
de prévention et d'accompagnement des
aidants merci madame waziers madame le
rapporteur
il y aurait d'autres 600 cd identique
694 rectifier
oui merci monsieur le président
effectivement c'est un un amendement qui
est qui est dit dans l'identité je crois
qu'on a pas mal débattu toute à l'heure
de la souffrance
des
des accompagnants et
peut-être que l'adoption d'ailleurs de
cet amendement permettra de dépasser les
oppositions que nous avons pu avoir et
qui sont très dommageables donc
effectivement je tiens à réaffirmer la
avec avec l'ensemble de mon groupe que
la fatigue physique et psychique les
enjeux affectifs et les stress
qu'implique cette fonction majeure
combiné à l'isolément des aidants
familiaux ont des répercussions vivent
sur leur propre santé d'après un récent
rapport il est estimé que les aidants
familiaux représentent près de 24 % des
arrêts maladie non prévue de courte
durée de trois à cinq jours et que le
taux d'absence non prévue de cette
population puisque tout à l'heure on
nous a parlé d'une population comme un
peu tout venant tu es de 40% supérieur à
celui des salariés n'ayant pas de
personne à charge donc ça c'est pas moi
qu'ils disent pas mon groupe c'est un
rapport qui le dit même si tu es mon
groupe où il faudra y faire cas
d'ailleurs donc il est vraiment urgent
que la politique de santé tel que le
prévoit le présent projet de loi dans
son article premier se saisissent de ce
sujet est en mesure l'importance ça a
été fait je dirais à mi chemin puisque
on a parlé des personnes handicapées ce
qui a quand même était un premier
progrès mais toujours pas des aidants
familiaux
donc c'est tout le sens de notre
amendement et nous sommes encore une
fois plusieurs sur des bancs différents
elle portait et j'espère que les
rapporteurs seront entendre ces voix là
merci madame cohen madame archimbaud sur
le 1085 recticel m
identique à celle même amendement la
fatigue physique et psychique les enjeux
affectifs le stress qu'implique cette
fonction majeure combiné à l'isolément
des aidants familiaux ont des
répercussions vivent sur leur propre
santé d'où la nécessité selon nous
également je rejoins ce qu'ont dit les
collègues que puisse être fait l'analyse
des risques psychosociaux qui pèsent sur
les aidants proches des études
épidémiologiques sur les pathologies
leurs coûts sociaux afin qu'on puisse
mettre en place là aussi une politique
de santé il sera dit national de santé
efficace en matière de prévention et
d'accompagnement des aidants d'humains
marche un beau madame le rapporteur sur
ces amendements identiques
votre préoccupation est partagée
elle est partagée par la commission des
affaires sociales est partagé par
l'ensemble des élus sur les territoires
on a vu se multiplier enfin je l'espère
sur vos territoires aussi mais les
initiatives concernant les aidants
familiaux qui ne sont pas exclusifs
d'ailleurs au problème du handicap
combien de groupes de paroles dead pour
prendre en charge la personne en
difficulté pour soulager les dents et je
voudrais simplement vous rappeler que la
caisse nationale de solidarité à
l'autonomie a produit un récent rapport
à qui sans doute demande à être
actualisée fréquemment et mais en
réalité ce rapport est tout à fait
conséquents et peut vous apporter
satisfaction donc comme nous l'avons dit
avec mes co rapporteurs les demandes de
rapports voilà n'ont pas forcément notre
approbation et surtout regarder ce qui
est déjà fait dans notre environnement
pour justement travaillé sur ces
situations et sur l'accompagnement des
aidants merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la ministre
a livré en toute rigueur je me retrouve
assez bien dans les propos que vient de
tenir madame la rapporteure il existe
des
et rapport il existe des études qui sont
produits par la cns à d'autres vont
l'être dans le cadre de la loi
d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement donc en réalité je ne
suis pas absolument certaine que la
production d'un nouveau rapport sera un
élément déterminant néanmoins moi j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure la demande de
beaucoup de sénateurs de voir pris en
considération les enjeux de santé des
aidants et pas simplement des personnes
handicapées et des aidants et donc il me
semble que et j'avais soutenu ces
amendements et donc par cohérence
je ne peux qu'être content ray être
sensible à la demande qui est exprimée
est donc entre ces deux arguments entre
le coeur et la raison disons que je vais
proposer la sagesse
merci madame la ministre
donc je suis j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen sur
les amendements 346 6 194 milles 4 - 5
qui sont je le rappelle identique
l'avis de la commission je vous le
rappelle est défavorable et l'avis du
gouvernement et la sagesse le scrutin
bien sûr sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
je vais vous donner le résultat donc de
ce scrutin sur les amendements 346
rectifié 694 rectifier et 1085 rectifié
nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 346 pour l'adoption
196 contre l'adoption 150 le sénat a
adopté
alors
au chapitre premier un amendement 695
qui est présenté par madame cohen
oui merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à corriger le titre du
chapitre premier qui s'intitule je vous
le rappelle soutenir les jeunes pour
l'égalité des chances en santé et qui se
trouve donc dans le titre renforcer la
prévention et la promotion de la santé
au niveau au niveau du groupe crc nous
pensons que d'une manière plus globale
parler d'égalité des chances ne revêt
pas la réalité de ce que vivent les
populations et nous préférons parler de
l'égalité des droits et c'est d'autant
plus vrai en matière de santé et c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons que ce titre du
chapitre premier s'intitule soutenir les
jeunes pour l'égalité des droits en
santé
en effet si on maintenait le titre en
l'état ça voudrait sous-entendre que en
fait les conditions de vie
l'appartenance sociale l'accès matériel
aux structures de soins la connaissance
du fonctionnement du système de santé
non pas que de conséquences pour les
jeunes dans l'accès aux soins et on le
sait bien dans les propos qui ont pu
être tenus par les uns et par les autres
il existe de véritables inégalités
sociales territoriales et que ce sont
ces inégalités là que nous devons
combattre
nous sommes donc
convaincue c'est le cas de le dire qu'il
faut prendre en considération les
nombreux travaux qui ont été faits à ce
sujet notamment je reviens sur les
travaux du géographe emmanuel vigneron
que nous avons d'ailleurs reçu dans une
audition ouverte à la commission des
affaires sociales qui nous a apporté
beaucoup et c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons que ce titre soit modifié et
que l'on parle d'égalité de droits en
matière de santé merci madame cohen
madame le rapporteur
la commission a émis un avis favorable à
la modification de l'intitulé du
chapitre 1er du titre premier projet de
loi
le rapporteur madame la ministre
écoutez je suis assez étonné moi je
comprends très bien l'objectif qui est
celui de votre amendement madame la
sénatrice et je reste convaincu que la
formulation initiale répondent mieux à
votre objectif que celle que vous
proposez l'égalité des droits c'est
regarder ce que sont les droits qui sont
proposées aux uns et aux autres et après
on pourrait rentrer dans la question de
savoir si ce sont des droits formels des
droits réels mais l'égalité des droits
de toutes façons elle existe dans notre
pays
et donc tout l'enjeu est de faire en
sorte que ces droits puisse s'exercer
dans un contexte qui est marqué par des
différences sociales des différences
territoriales des différences
culturelles et c'est tout cela qu'il
faut prendre en compte et donc il faut
transformer les droits en chances
objectives en chance pour chacune et
chacun il faut donner à chaque citoyen
au delà des droits qu'ils possèdent la
même chance de pouvoir utiliser ses
droits et les faire fructifier donc je
vous le dis moi je reste attaché la
formulation initiale du texte que j'ai
proposé qui me semble beaucoup plus
conforme aux objectifs que vous
recherchez et intégré bien davantage la
diversité
des situations et des situations
subjectif culturels politiques
territoriales qui font obstacle au bon
exercice des droits dont je vous demande
plutôt de retirer votre amendement sinon
avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre monsieur barbier
mais monsieur le président pour une fois
moi je sais pas ce soir mais je suis
d'accord avec madame le ministre parce
que parler de l'égalité des droits c'est
la constitution c'est que nous avons
tous les mêmes droits cette salle veut
rien dit a pratiquement où ça veut tout
dire je pense qu'effectivement c'est
l'égalité des chances c'est à dire qu'on
puisse à moment donné que ces jeunes
puissent accéder
à ses droits ses chefs aient chacun leur
chance sentiers ce qu'est le cas on sait
très bien en fonction des localisations
en fonction la situation sociale mais
l'égalité des droits elles existent de
par la constitution donc je pense que la
formulation la ministre me paraît
préférable
si monsieur barbier madame cohen
je ne partage pas évidemment les avis
qu'ils viennent d'être donnés par ce que
je voudrais qu'on m'explique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire l'égalité des
chances en santé on n'est pas tous égaux
à la naissance
parce qu'on peut avoir effectivement des
problèmes d'ordre génétique
on peut avoir des des handicaps ou peut
avoir l'égalité des chances ça n'existe
pas en tant que tel en matière de santé
et donc c'est bien des droits à
conquérir
et quand même ça se saurait mes chers
collègues si le fait que ce soit dans la
constitution l'égalité des droits il
soit garantie par tous pour tous sur
tout le territoire on légifère
constamment pour justement faire en
sorte de faire reculer les inégalités
sociales territoriales en faisant en
sorte que les mêmes droits existent pour
tout citoyen pour tous tout citoyenne
donc parler d'égalité des chances en
matière de santé ne me semble pas juste
sur le plan politique et ne semble
absolument pas juste sur le sur la
réalité mêmes qui fait que effectivement
on n'est pas égaux à la naissance pour
des tas de facteurs qui sont y compris
d'ailleurs indépendant pour certains de
ce qui peut être de nature sociale
économique et c'est donc je plaide pour
que soit reconnu l'égalité des droits en
matière de santé ce qui correspond à un
combat plus juste une réalité plus juste
par rapport à ce que l'on porte
merci madame cohen il y at il d'autres
explications de vote
je mets donc aux voix
cet amendement
695 qui est pour rappel of un avis
favorable de la commission et un avis de
retrait ou défavorable du gouvernement
alors qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté
est ainsi donc
indigènes le chapitre premier
avant l'article d'un amendement 680 13
l'objet d'une discussion commune qui est
présenté par mcqueen monsieur watrin à
rien oui merci monsieur le président la
santé des jeunes est un objectif
prioritaire naturellement visés par le
projet de loi conformément aux
orientations la stratégie nationale de
santé celui-ci occulte cependant la
santé des jeunes enfants avant l'âge de
3 ans qui ne sont pas scolarisés selon
l'unicef le taux de pauvreté des enfants
est passée en france de 15 6 10 8 6
entre 2008 et 2012 ce qui correspond à
une augmentation d'environ 440 mille
enfants pauvres l'enquète du samu social
de paris de 2014 auprès de familles
hébergées à l'hôtel est également
alarmante plus de 80% des familles sous
le seuil de pauvreté près de huit
familles sur 10 et deux enfants sur
trois en insécurité alimentaire
ces différents constats rend nécessaire
le développement d'actions l'égard des
parents et des enfants avant leur
scolarisation
ces actions destinées au développement
de la petite enfance sont en effet
indispensables pour non seulement
améliorer l'état de santé des enfants
mais également soutenir les parents et
agir ainsi sur les déterminants de santé
nous demandons donc à travers cet
amendement de promouvoir la santé dès la
petite enfance
merci monsieur watrin le
883 rectifié bis madame 1
d'abord merci monsieur le président donc
cet amendement est identique et il a été
fort bien défendu par mes collègues et
je crois que pour l'égalité des droits
en santé donc selon pour nécessite
l'accompagnement des parents pendant les
premières années de vie de l'enfant je
crois qu'en effet il faut mettre tout
notre poids sur la caisse nationale des
allocations familiales et sur service
départemental de la pmi donc moi je suis
pour bien sûr le même amendement
j'espère que beaucoup de nous suivrons
merci merci madame laborde madame le
rapporteur
les deux amendements sont quasiment
identiques
à ceci près que la retient la notion
d'égalité des droits est l'autre celle
d'égalité des chances en santé alors ces
amendements visent à réaffirmer la
nécessité d'un accompagnement des
parents pendant les premières années de
la vie de l'enfant il dispose que la
cnaf et les services de la pmi mettent
en place des actions de promotion
de la santé qui concourent à
l'amélioration de la santé des enfants
et de leurs parents alors la commission
des affaires sociales partage la
préoccupation des auteurs des
amendements mais nous émettons plusieurs
réserves qui nous conduisent à donner un
avis défavorable en effet la portée
normative de la première phase la
première phrase ne semble pas assurée et
la seconde relève de l'action sociale
extra légale des caf qui est organisé
par voie de circulaire elle est
satisfaite par le droit en vigueur il
convient de rappeler à cet égard
l'article l 21 aux tirs et 1 du code de
la santé publique selon lequel l'état
les collectivités territoriales les
organismes de sécurité sociale participe
dans les conditions prévues par le
présent livre par le présent livre à la
protection et la promotion de la santé
maternelle et infantile qui comprend
notamment des mesures de prévention
médicale psychologique sociale et
d'éducation pour la santé en faveur des
futurs parents et des enfants des
actions d'accompagnement psychologique
et sociale des femmes enceintes et de
jeunes mères de famille particulièrement
les plus démunis des actions de
prévention et de dépistage des handicaps
des enfants de moins de 6 ans ainsi que
de conseils aux familles pour la prise
en charge de ces handicaps la
surveillance et le contrôle des
établissements et services d'accueil des
enfants de moins de 6 ans ainsi que le
contrôle la surveillance et
l'accompagnement des assistants
maternels
mentionnée à l'article l 421 tirer 1 du
code de l'action sociale et des familles
compte tenu de ces dispositions il ne
paraît pas fondée de raffinement et par
ailleurs dans la loi la nécessité d'un
accompagnement de la petite enfance donc
un avis défavorable merci madame le
rapporteur madame la ministre oui je
t'aime aussi un avis défavorable là
encore non pas parce que l'objectif ne
serait pas
plus que défendable positif et
évidemment à apporter mais parce que des
dispositions existent déjà dans le code
de la santé publique qui prévoit
les actions qui sont proposés par cet
amendement donc il me semble que cet
amendement est satisfait et c'est pour
cela que s'il n'est pas retirée je donne
un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre
je mets aux voix alors je mets au voile
693 qui est pour
et qui est contre
il n'est pas adoptée même vote pour le
883 rectifié bis même vote il n'est pas
adoptée à l'article 2 55 amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
1 457 qui présenté par madame
alima chers collègues
la ministre chaque collègue nous
déplorons souvent le grand foisonnement
de nos dispositifs de santé publique
dans le fonctionnement quotidien et
c'est d'autant plus vrai en matière de
médecine scolaire où les médecins et les
infirmières rencontrent dans leur
pratique quotidienne de grandes
difficultés à permettre une continuité
de la prise en charge des enfants
souvent par manque de lien avec les
autres acteurs de santé tels que les
médecins de ville où la pmi la
coordination des différents acteurs de
santé est un élément essentiel
d'amélioration de notre système et de
notre efficacité en particulier en
matière de prévention pour créer les
conditions d'une politique publique de
santé scolaire cohérente à tous les
échelons il est donc essentiel pour nous
que les acteurs de la prévention soient
clairement identifiés et travaille plus
en complémentarité dans le cadre de
réseaux réseaux internes à l'éducation
nationale au niveau nation al rectorat
les départementales bien sûr mais aussi
réseaux externes de partenariat
multiforme avec les collectivités
locales les services les acteurs de
santé extérieures au système scolaire ou
dans le milieu associatif
les liens entre les services de santé
scolaire services de prévention
territorialisée services de santé
ambulatoire et services hospitaliers
doivent être développées il convient de
créer le cadre législatif de ce
rapprochement et de cette coordination
il nous faut créer ainsi les conditions
de l'articulation entre les acteurs
relevant de l'éducation nationale et les
acteurs relevant du ministère de la
santé des affaires sociales pour une
meilleure prise en charge globale et
transversale de l'enfant déjà lors de
l'examen de loi de prise en charge
pardon de la réfondation de l'école nous
avions ici au sénat plaidé pour
introduire une définition une définition
conjointe avec le ministère de
l'éducation nationale et celui de la
santé d'un contenu d'une périodicité des
bilans de dépistage obligatoire dans le
cadre de la médecine scolaire donc voici
l'objet de notre amendement pour
rétablir l'article 2 dans sa rédaction
telle issue à l'assemblée nationale
merci madame monnier le 646 qui est
présenté par madame la ministre
allemande du gouvernement
oui c'est la volonté du gouvernement de
rétablir les dispositions qui ont été
supprimée en commission des affaires
sociales gelé indiqué tout à l'heure
dans mon intervention liminaire je
présenterai des amendements de
rétablissement des dispositions qui me
paraissent
les plus importantes et les plus
structurantes pour le projet de loi que
je vous présente cet article 2 à
l'article 2 tel qu'il
existait préalablement à aux décisions
ou au vote de la commission des affaires
sociales permettait d'établir un
parcours éducatif en santé pourquoi
parce que tout le monde constate que la
santé elle se construit dès l'enfance et
qu'il y a des réflexes des comportements
d habitude à acquérir dès l'enfance et
que les inégalités de santé elle se noue
à ce moment là non pas en raison de
droits objectif mais en raison de
conditions de vie de capacité à être
informés et à quel que soit son milieu
social quels que soient les habitudes
culturelles des parents quel que soit le
lieu d'habitation
quel que soit l'école dans laquelle on
est
scolarisé à la capacité donc à acquérir
c'est bon réflexe est donc l'enjeu qui
est absolument fondamental c'est de d'en
finir avec le poète non pas l'opposition
mais la séparation qui existe
aujourd'hui entre ce qui se passe dans
le secteur de la santé de ville et ce
qui se passe à l'école de faire en sorte
que les priorités de santé publique elle
telles qu'elles sont définies pour le
pays soit intégrée dans le dans un
parcours éducatif qui ne sera évidemment
pas un cours de santé mais qui intégrera
à partir de la maternelle jusqu'au lycée
dans les programmes dans l'enseignement
dans les activités de l'école les
priorités les messages d'information les
messages de prévention qui doivent être
mis en avant donc l'esprit de cet arc x
est véritablement que pour la première
fois la loi propose une mise en
cohérence des objectifs de santé
publique défini par le ministère chargé
de la santé et les actions menées en
faveur de la santé des enfants au sein
de l'éducation nationale c'est donc un
arctique tout à fait important dont je
vous propose le rétablissement
merci ministre de 696 qui est présenté
par mme anne david oui merci monsieur le
président en effet nous avons un
amendement qui est tout à fait identique
à celui présenté à l'instant par le
groupe socialiste et par le gouvernement
et nous partageons complètement
l'objectif que vient de rappeler madame
la ministre à savoir d'inscrire
clairement la promotion de la santé à
l'école comme l'une des composantes
essentielles de la politique de santé et
d'insister sur la nécessité d'une bonne
articulation entre lens la santé en
milieu scolaire et les priorités de la
stratégie nationale de santé c'est un
article en effet qui nous semble très
important puisque à la suite en plus de
l'adoption à l'assemblée nationale de
deux amendements en séance publique
l'article prévoit que la mission de
promotion de la santé à l'école soit
également conduite dans les instituts
médico éducatifs etc elle veille
également à sensibiliser l'environnement
familial des élèves afin d'assurer une
appropriation large des problématiques
de santé publique nous partageons donc
complètement ses objectifs et remettons
en cause les doutes avancés par la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat bien que celle ci ait soulevé une
interrogation très pertinente
la question des moyens pouvant y être
associés associés
nous saluons d'ailleurs à cette occasion
la demande de nos collègues de droite
d'une augmentation de la dépense
publique de notre côté nous ne sommes
pas dupes et nous attendons avec
impatience le budget des affaires
sociales pour l'année 2016 qui nous
l'espérons viendra apporter des réponses
à ce souci légitime des ressources en
attendant comment se dire ambitieux pour
la santé des jeunes et supprimer cet
article c'est un signal très négatif
adressé au monde de l'éducation qui
demande au contraire des mesures pour
renforcer les gars l'accès à la santé
pour les jeunes c'est pourquoi nous vous
invitons à voter cette avance amendement
de rétablissement qui va véritablement
dans le sens d'un renforcement de la
prévention et de la promotion de la
santé et cela commence par la santé
scolaire
merci madame david madame archambault
pour qui est identique oui rapidement et
c'est le sait le même amendement avec
les mêmes motifs nécessité de mise en
cohérence
nécessité aussi d'avoir une gouvernance
claire de la politique de santé à
l'école donc les actions de promotion de
la santé en milieu scolaire soit conduit
conformément aux orientations nationales
de la politique de santé c'est vrai que
lorsque les parlementaires ont souhaité
parler dans la loi de réformation de
l'école de la santé alors répondu que
cela relevait plutôt de la loi de santé
alors aujourd'hui
justement parlons-en et mettons et
mettant en cohérence
tout cela c'est vrai je rejoins ce qui a
été dit sur le fait que l'apprentissage
de la santé doit commencer dès l'enfance
et donc dès l'école team de marche un
beau 1 878 rectifié qui est présentée
par monsieur roquet oui merci mme
jeannine chaque collègue la suppression
de cet article en commission est
dommageable qui existent le gramme de
misère de la médecine scolaire et
commandant de préciser cet article pas
de supprimer et d'acier par cet
amendement les actions de promotion de
la santé en milieu scolaire conduite par
les autorités académiques en lien avec
les bagarres régal de santé nous pensons
que c'est mieux en le disant et à
l'écrivain
merci monsieur roquet alors madame la
rapporteure tout en sachant qu'il y en a
quatre qui sont identiques et un pas
identiques
donc ces différents amendements visent à
rétablir l'article 2 du projet de loi
qui a été supprimée par la commission
des affaires sociales en juillet alors
l'article 2 du projet de loi vise à
indiquer que les actions promotion de
son terminus colère sont conduites
conformément aux orientations nationales
politiques de santé par les autorités
académiques en lien avec les ars bien
évidemment nous ne pouvons que partager
l'idée selon laquelle l'école constitue
un lieu privilégié pour les actions de
promotion la santé dès le plus jeune âge
par les deux parcours éducatif de santé
qui pourraient dans cet hémicycle être
contre néanmoins nous avons souhaité
supprimer l'article de karine ne permet
aucune avancée concrète dans ce domaine
les textes législatifs et réglementaires
en vigueur à signe déjà une double
mission à l'école celle de suivre l'état
de santé des élèves et celle de
contribuer à leur éducation à la santé
celle ci fait partie du socle commun de
connaissances de compétences et de
culture prévues à l'article l 122-1
terrain du code de l'éducation
elle est formalisée dans le projet
d'école et le projet d'établissement
dans les collèges et les lycées le
comité d'éducation à la santé et à la
citoyenneté la met en pratique sur le
terrain les parts l'air extérieur
institutionnels ou associatifs et je ne
vais pas tous les citer apportent leur
concours en menant des actions de
prévention d'information ou en
développement des ressources
pédagogiques
s'agissant des rs l'article l 1400 31-2
du code de la santé publique le racing
déjà la mission de mettre en oeuvre au
niveau régional la politique de santé en
liaison avec les autorités compétentes
dans le domaine de la santé scolaire et
universitaire à ce titre elles
définissent et finance des actions
visant à promouvoir la santé à éduquer
la population à la santé et à prévenir
les maladies le handicap et la perte
d'autonomie
la question de l'émergence d'un bac
parcours éducatif de santé pose aussi la
question des moyens et du temps pouvant
être consacré or comme l'indiquent
l'étude d'impact annexée au projet de
loi les orientations définies à
l'article 2 ne reposeront sur aucun
dispositif supplémentaire la mise en
place de mesures relèvent des politiques
académiques et d'établissements elle est
donc financé à moyens constants par les
ressources de l'éducation nationale et
des ars dans le cadre des projets
régionaux de santé l'article 2 n'est
d'ailleurs pas nécessaire pour permettre
le redéploiement de crédits tel qu'il
est prévu dans certains amendements
enfin l'étude d'impact ne prévoit aucun
texte d'application de cet article pour
toutes ces raisons la commission
maintient son avis défavorable au
rétablissement l'article 2
merci mesdames le rapporteur madame la
ministre
les amendements sont presque tous
identiques sauf celui de monsieur amiel
qui a une rédaction légèrement
différente qui nous
rajoute un alinéa par rapport aux autres
amendements donc je lui demanderais
plutôt de retirer son amendement
pour
être dans la lignée des autres si j'ose
dire et je donne un avis évidemment
favorable à ces amendements puisque je
moi même au nom du gouvernement proposer
d'amendement je voudrais néanmoins
précisé qu'il y aura des textes
réglementaires d'application de cet
article qui doivent notamment définir
depuis la maternelle jusqu'au lycée la
nature des de ce parcours éducatif et
des éléments qui doivent être portées à
la connaissance à l'information des
élèves indique par ailleurs que le haut
conseil pour la santé publique a exprimé
à de très nombreuses reprises le fait
que c'était à partir de la mise en place
d'éléments d'information à l'école que
l'on pourrait réduire significativement
les inégalités mais je veux encore une
fois précisé qu' il n'y aura pas une
heure de santé dans le programme des
enfants il y aura par exemple en
maternelle des activités qui pourront
prendre comme sujet l'hygiène et à
partir de plusieurs activités on va dans
un jardin on fait du jardinage qu'on
fait souvent en maternelle on reviendra
et on se lavera les mains et on parlera
du fait de se laver les mains ou on se
lavera les dents des éléments de ce type
là mais y aura pas de 8h à 9h ou de 11h
à 12h le cours de santé à l'école c'est
intégrer les enjeux de santé dans les
programmes qui sont de français de maths
d'histoire ou d'autre chose on peut
faire des dictées sur des sujets de
santé on peut faire des mathématiques à
partir de d'enjeux de santé et c'est
bien cela qui est proposée par cet
article 2
merci madame la ministre
donc je vais mettre aux voix
les commencer par l'allemand moment 457
qui est l'identique du 640 6 696 et 1025
qui est pour
aya une demande de scrutin public
excusez moi donc j'ai été saisi d'une
demande il y avait une explication de
vote
bien
c'était l'amendement après mais très
bien comme ça les choses sont claires
monsieur roch et je remercie
donc scrutin public qui a été demandé
par la commission sur les amendements
qui sont identiques je viens de rappeler
l'avis de la commission vous le savez
défavorable et l'avis du gouvernement
est favorable
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 de notre règlement
bien je vais vous donner les résultats
donc du scrutin numéro 2 143 sur les
amendements
457 646 696 et 1025 nombre de votants
343 nombre de suffrages exprimés 343
pour l'adoption 155 contre l'adoption
188 le sénat n'a pas adopté et l'article
2 reste dans que supprimer
après l'article de un amendement 1027
qui est présenté par madame archambault
oui c'est un amendement qui propose donc
enfin qui insiste sur le fait que les
élèves peuvent rencontrer un infirmier
ou un médecin l'éducation nationale dès
qu'ils en font la demande ou si leur
état de santé physique psychique ou
cognitif a des conséquences sur
l'apprentissage c'est voilà c'est on
insiste sur 7
sur cette possibilité d'un accès rapide
on sait que cela peut permettre une
détection précoce des troubles de
l'apprentissage et et c'est aussi un tel
accès qui peut renforcer l'égalité
d'accès aux soins pour l'ensemble des
élèves du système scolaire
merci me martimbault madame leur
apportera
alors un cet amendement vise à préciser
que dans le cadre de la mission de
promotion de la santé école les élèves
ont accès à un infirmier ou un médecin
de l'éducation nationale dès qu'il le
demande alors certes on connaît les
difficultés auxquelles fait face la
médecine scolaire mais néanmoins le
principe est déjà dans la loi celui de
l'accès un infirmier un médecin de
l'éducation nationale est certes on peut
le remettre
un vitam aeternam dans tous les textes
ça résoudra pas le problème de la
médecine scolaire la loi est là et après
il faut se donner les moyens de
l'appliquer sur le territoire mais on
peut on peut remettre dix fois les mêmes
choses dans les lois le saut ne change
rien au problème du territoire et du
terrain
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre
oui je vous demanderai de retirer votre
amendement sinon un avis défavorable
là encore non pas sur le principe mais
le principe peu figure à l'article l 121
1-4-1
du code de l'éducation et donc
votre
comment dire
votre volonté en quelque sorte est
exaucé
voilà donc demande de retrait ou avis
défavorable
l'unisson de mme archambault
oui je ne sais pas si on donnera la
possibilité mais un peu plus loin dans
le texte nous proposeront également
des amendements pour
valoriser davantage
les réseaux de médecins scolaires plus
exactement les mettre en coordination et
en coopération plus étroite avec
l'ensemble des réseaux de professionnels
de santé ce qui ne semble là aussi qui
sont en quelque sorte sous-employés ce
serait sans doute une façon de répondre
à ces difficultés nous avons déposé cet
amendement pour pour souligner à quel
point il ya une vraie difficulté quoi et
alors je sais pas quand on pourra
aborder cette question et surtout
trouver des solutions concrètes moi je
vais retirer mon amendement mais le
problème reste et on connaît tous des
établissements dans lesquels
malheureusement
pour pouvoir rencontrer le médecin
scolaire il faut vraiment être très très
très malade ou avoir très très gros
problème quoi donc c'est cesser une
situation préoccupante sur laquelle nous
nous voulions assister on y reviendra un
peu plus tard dans des bas
mais
j'ai pas entendu marc chabot
non
madame archambault
il est relié
après l'article 2
un amendement 458 qui est présenté par
madame alima chers collègues
et lui nyonnais
monsieur le président merci madame
oui
sérieusement donc sur l'amendement 458
il apporte une précision sur le champ de
mission de promotion de la santé à
l'école notamment ce qui concerne les
acteurs et les actions concernant
l'article l 121 4 1 du code de
l'éducation
donc il s'agit de compléter des
initiatives institutionnelles en matière
de prévention et d'éducation à la santé
par des actions de proximité de
prévention partager favorisant la
participation des publics cibles à
l'école comme dans la société en général
il faut pouvoir s'adapter à la cible
mais aussi savoir l'impliquer pour qu
elle ce qu'elle se sente concerné
responsabilités donc voilà en d'autres
termes il faut faire pour mais aussi
avec c'est ce qu'on appelle la
prévention partager
si de telles initiatives existent déjà à
la lumière de leur réussite il nous
semble nécessaire de les développer les
généraliser tel est l'objet de cet
amendement merci madame lyonnais
madame le rapporteur
cet amendement temps reconnaître la
contribution des acteurs de proximité
non professionnels de santé à la
promotion de la santé à l'école
l'expression acteurs de proximité non
professionnels de santé nous a paru
assez peu intelligible s'il s'agit de
partenaires associatifs de nombreuses
associations agréées par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale interviennent déjà
l'école dans le domaine de l'éducation à
la citoyenneté et à la santé citerai apf
avenir santé france crips mouvement pour
planning familial enfance et partage etc
il revient aux chefs d'établissement de
se prononcer sur la demande que les
associations doivent formuler à chaque
intervention dans ces conditions il n'a
pas paru nécessaire à la commission de
prévoir une nouvelle disposition
latif et c'est donc une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable modem le
rapporteur madame la ministre
mais pour ma part je donne un avis
favorable à cet amendement qui propose
un cadre juridique à des actions qui se
développe déjà sur le terrain puisque
des acteurs qui ne sont pas strictement
éducatif ou strictement sanitaire
concours d'ores et déjà à des actions en
faveur de la santé des enfants y compris
en milieu éducatif donc je donne un avis
favorable à cette à cet amendement car
si madame la ministre je le mets aux
voix qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
après l'article de un amendement
présenté par madame archambault l'omi 31
mai d'un marchand beau
oui très très rapidement le code de
l'éducation prévoit une information et
une éducation à l'alimentation si le
lien entre l'alimentation et la santé
primordial il apparaît nécessaire de le
rendre explicite une deux une des façons
de le faire nous semble-t-il serait de
rappeler qu on peut notamment dans les
repas introduire des produits
biologiques je développe peut-être pas
davantage mais ça paraît pédagogiquement
intéressant de sensibiliser les enfants
les futurs citoyens directement
concrètement lorsqu on leur distribue
des repas merci même à chabot madame le
rapporteur
cet amendement vise à préciser que
l'éducation des élèves à l'alimentation
est dispensé dans le cadre des repas
scolaires notamment autour de
l'introduction de repas biologique il
nous semble qu'il n'appartient pas la
loi de définir les modalités selon
lesquelles la mise en oeuvre l'éducation
des élèves à l'alimentation de plus sur
le terrain de nombreuses collectivités
se sont déjà engagés dans l'introduction
produits biologiques dans leurs cantines
il ne semble donc pas nécessaire de
prévoir cette possibilité dans la loi
c'est un avis défavorable merci même le
rapporteur madame la ministre je teins
aussi un avis défavorable parce que le
lien entre
santé et alimentation
ne relève pas de la loi mais de
directives de d'arrêter de circulaire du
ministère de l'éducation nationale le
cas échéant et vous pouvez par exemple
aller sur le site internet et du skol
qui donne toute une série d'informations
et de conseils aux enseignants et aux
chefs d'établissement en matière
d'alimentation et de liens entre santé
alimentation donc avis défavorable merci
madame la ministre
je le mets aux voix
qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté
deux amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune après l'article de
toujours 2029 madame archambault
l'article l312 17 3 du code de
l'éducation porte sur l'éducation
à l'alimentation dans les écoles ans
nous observons depuis plusieurs années
une présence importante de goût groupes
d'intérêts privés dans les écoles qui
promeuvent la consommation de tel ou tel
produit en minimisant les impacts sur la
santé ou en alléguant des vertus
sanitaires très souvent biaisée c'est le
cas par exemple du partenariat qui avait
été conclu en 2013 entre le cedus lobby
de l'industrie sucrière et l'éducation
nationale ce partenariat prévoyait des
actions de sensibilisation à la
nutrition la distribution de brochures
d'information dans les écoles par le
cedus dans le cedus défend un intérêt
particulier ces outils de communication
de sensibilisation sont très souvent
biaisée il minimise où il élude le lien
entre par exemple la consommation
excessive de sucre industriel est la
recrudescence de certaines maladies
notons par ailleurs que ces partenariats
existent également au niveau des
rectorats ou des établissements donc
sans interdire ces partenariats s'agit
pas de les interdire le présent
amendement prévoit qu'il soit validé par
les ars
lorsqu'ils concernent les établissements
et par le ministère de la santé
lorsqu'il concerne ministère de
l'éducation nationale c'est pour nous
une question importante
symbole le mythe prendre toujours madame
archambault
celle même la seule chose qui change
c'est parce que ça avait été suggérée en
commission c'est que
ce soit l'inp est-ce
qu'ils soient en quelque sorte
responsable du pilotage de la
surveillance pour vérifier que l'intérêt
général est bien respectée de c2c
partenariat plutôt que les ars voilà
c'est un amendement dans quelque sorte
de repli et qui tient compte de ce qui
avait été dit en commission quand on en
a parlé à marc chabot madame le
rapporteur pour le but de commissions
oui alors le premier amendement en effet
entendait assigné aux rs la mission de
valider les conventions de partenariat
passé entre un établissement
d'enseignement et les organismes
représentant un intérêt privé en matière
d'éducation à la santé alors il a semblé
à la commission que c'était une en effet
une idée intéressante mais que ce
n'était sans doute pas aux ars qui ont
déjà fort à faire d'assurer cette
mission
c'est donc une demande de retrait un
avis défavorable sur le premier
amendement sur l'amendement suivant qui
transmet à l'inp sd convention de
partenariat conclue entre les
établissements d'enseignement est un
organisme privé en matière d'éducation à
la santé cette solution nous paraissait
intéressante néanmoins n'est pas sans
soulever sans soulever quelques
questions est-ce que l'hymne ps doit
être le simple destinataires ces
documents doit-il émettre un avis
consultatif quelles seraient les suites
à donner à un avis négatif ou réserver
de sapins d'autre part l'amendement ne
semble pas d'ailleurs visé le bon
article du code de santé publique car il
est question du cas programme à
l'article l32 32-1 mais compte tenu de
toutes ces considérations il a été
proposé par la commission de solliciter
l'avis du gouvernement merci même
l'emportera madame la ministre
je donne un avis défavorable si vous
voulez maintenez à avaux deux
amendements madame la sénatrice il y a
eu un dysfonctionnement
cette affaire du cedus qui était très
choquant d'ailleurs mais qui a permis de
voir qu'il y avait des failles dans la
dans le contrôle des partenariats qui
pouvait être noués entre des
établissements et des organismes entre
guillemets porteurs d'intérêts
alimentaire mais c'est la responsabilité
de l'éducation nationale de procéder à
ces contrôles il s'agit d'établissements
de l'éducation nationale et je ne vois
pas comment le ministère de la santé ou
des agences relevant du ministère de la
santé viendrait de l'extérieur contrôler
des partenariats entre des
établissements et des organismes sur la
base formelle de l'existence ou non de
conflit d'intérêt il ne s'agit pas de
porter un intérêt on va pas se mettre à
apprécier l'opportunité au cas par cas
de tous les partenariats qui peuvent
exister ce sont les rectorats qui sont
en lien direct avec leur établissement
qui peuvent apprécier l'opportunité la
qualité des partenariats proposés et
éventuellement
l'opportunité pas là là là le bien fondé
de ces partenariats dont je donne un
avis défavorable parce que cela ne me
semble pas relever de la responsabilité
et des fonctions ni des ars ni de l'inp
s dans ce cas précis
merci madame la ministre madame un char
beau pour explication de vote je
maintiens au moins le deuxième
amendement jeu vient d'enlever le
premier si on considère en effet que les
ars ont fort à faire par ailleurs mais
il me semble pas évident
que l'éducation nationale avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour cette grand
ministère et toujours les moyens de
juger jusque là on l'a on se retrouve se
trouve à nouveau devant un problème de
gouvernance et de transversalité
je pense qu'il ya une vraie une vraie
difficulté je comprends bien que c'est
difficile à régler comme ça mais il ya
une difficulté je ne vois pas je ne suis
pas sûr qu'au sein du mr l'éducation
nationale on puisse traiter de façon
aussi pointue ces questions de santé
quand elle se pose
donc je maintiens deuxième amendement
merci mme archambault alors le premier
amendement est retiré le deuxième le
1030 je le mets aux voix qui est pour
et qui est contre
on va recompter qui est pour
qui est contre
qui et s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée
après l'article 2 toujours un amendement
459 qui est présentée par monsieur la
base est géré par un monsieur la vase et
merci monsieur le président
voilà il est d'usagé de rappeler
un préalable important dans nos débats
la vaccination est avait l'hygiène la
première arme de prévention et de lutte
contre les maladies infectieuses
faisant de la stratégie vaccinale
l'enjeu majeur de santé publique
pour y répondre il est urgent d'adapter
des instruments de suivi et de contrôle
de la vaccination
c'est pourquoi il convient d'associer
pleinement l'éducation nationale aux
stratégies de vaccination
cet amendement propose ainsi de modifier
l'article l541 1 du code de l'éducation
relative aux actions de promotion de la
santé des élèves en permettant aux
élèves de bénéficier d'un suivi de leur
couverture vaccinale nous voulons lutter
contre les disparités de taux de
couverture entre les territoires mais
aussi en fonction des vaccins il s'agit
également de repérer les enfants devant
faire l'objet de stratégies vaccinales
particulière mais aussi de développer
l'accès des populations en situation de
précarité au vaccin nous avions discuté
de ce problème lors du débat sur la
refondation de l'école pour des raisons
matérielles on n'avait pas pu aller plus
loin mais il avait reçu également un
avis favorable du ministre de
l'éducation de l'époque
merci monsieur la base et madame
donc le suivi de la couverture vaccinale
des enfants et des adolescents relève
aujourd'hui des enquêtes de l'inpes
l'institut national de veille sanitaire
compte tenu des enjeux
rencontré il apparaît en effet
nécessaire de renforcer suivies dans le
cadre santé scolaire même s'ils se pose
toujours la question des moyens de
médecine scolaire et à ce titre la
commission a donné un avis favorable
merci le rapporteur
madame le ministre
comprends la préoccupation qui est
exprimée et vous savez l'engagement qui
est le mien pour
favoriser une meilleure couverture
vaccinale dans notre pays certaines
situations étant extrêmement
problématique et la défiance à l'égard
des vaccins
augmentant de manière préoccupante et en
particulier pour certains vaccins qui ne
sont pas forcément d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
sont
10 ont proposé aux enfants le suivi
vaccinal dans la pratique il est
effectué à l'école
l'enjeu c'est moins qu'il y ait un suivi
vaccinal que de l'homogénéiser selon les
territoires et de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient la même un même calendrier des
vous savez j'ai annoncé qu'il y aurait
un grand débat sur la vaccination à
l'automne à la suite de la remise d'un
rapport par une parlementaire une
députée madame hurel et c'est à partir
de là que des dispositions doivent être
prises je comprends très bien la
préoccupation qui est la vôtre c'est
pour ça qu'il faut donner un avis de
sagesse mais je ne crois pas très
sincèrement que ce soit le lieu
d'inscription de ces dispositions nous
avons besoin en réalité de mesures
réglementaires et pas de mesures
législatives qui permettent de définir
un calendrier
homogène pour l'ensemble des écoles de
france et c'est à partir des
préconisations remises par madame hurel
et ce qui ressortira du débat qui
s'ensuivra que les dispositions
réglementaires seront prises mais je ne
veux pas avoir l'air de bloquer enfin ou
de donner un avis qui serait perçu comme
défavorables à votre objectif donc d'un
avis de sagesse tout en indiquant que
sur le plan de la méthode à suivre je
crois que c'est dû au niveau
réglementaire
merci madame la ministre
alors sur la base et
tout va bien bien alors on va voter qui
et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient eh bien vous avez raison
il est adopté monsieur la base et
après l'article de un amendement 1026
qui est présenté par madame archambault
cet amendement vise à ce que les
étudiants en formation médicale
paramédicale sanitaires sociales
puissent à la demande des enseignants
intervenir à l'école pour des actions de
prévention et de promotion de santé
localement ce sont des actions qui se
mènent déjà dans certains endroits
depuis une dizaine d'années qui sont
conduites par le biais des bureaux des
étudiants associations locales étudiants
d'une même filière d'une même structure
universitaire elles sont réalisées le
plus souvent sur le temps libre des
étudiants soutenus pour la plupart par
les facultés ou les instituts qui les
abrite ce sont des opérations qui
s'adresse à l'ensemble de la population
sur des thèmes très larges tels que
l'alimentation la consommation d'alcool
la pratique d'activités physiques
sportives ou la santé sexuelle par
exemple or les associations étudiantes
font face à de nombreux défis pour créer
faire perdurer leur programme
d'éducation à la santé trouver des
financements être soutenus dans leur
établissement de rattachement obtenir
l'autorisation d'intervenir en effet
les associations étudiantes du seul fait
qu'elle soit composée d'étudiants d'une
même filière et de représentants d'un
corps ne peuvent pas bénéficier du titre
d'associations d'intérêt général ne sont
ainsi pas reconnus comme acteurs de
prévention et en plus de difficultés à
mener leurs actions et donc la création
d'un agrément spécifique pour ces
associations locales d'étudiants en
santé permettrait donc de favoriser ses
actions de les associer au réseau de
prévention régionaux coordonnée par la
rs et enfin de les intégrer au sein des
cursus de formation en sciences
médicales et paramédicales
je précise que c'est un amendement qui
est proposée par certaines associations
d'étudiants en médecine ça il me
paraîtrait
fassi proposition me paraissent utiles
en général
beau madame
de roche
demande d'associations d'étudiants en
formation médicale par les ars pour
intervenir à l'école
merci favorable merci mon neveu le
rapporteur madame la ministre
oui je donne aussi un avis défavorable
parce que en tout cas dans la
présentation que vous faites et puis ce
qui ressort de votre amendement il y a
un côté systématique qui peut être
qui peut poser un certain nombre de
difficultés il ya d'ores et déjà des
jeunes étudiants des étudiants en
médecine ou en professions de santé qui
interviennent dans le cadre scolaire
dans le cadre de stages avec disons un
encadrement qui est identifié et qui
s'inscrit dans une stratégie
définie par la médecine scolaire on ne
peut pas ouvrir de façon
non régulés
l'exercice de certaines de certains
actes ou de certaines ou de la promotion
de la santé à des étudiants en médecine
d'une manière qui ne serait pas encadrer
ce qui ne s'inscrirait pas dans un
contexte bien identifiées donc je donne
un avis défavorable le même la ministre
mais aux voix cet amendement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté un
amendement 676 qui est présentée par
monsieur la base et
oui merci monsieur le président
dans un rapport intitulé la politique
vaccinale de la france fait au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat en février 2013 et que j'avais
présenté je proposais de mettre en place
l'enseignement de la prévention en
matière de santé à l'école je crois que
nous avons beaucoup débattu ce soir
l'amendement que je défends présent va
dans ce sens et modifie l'article l7 121
2 du code de l'éducation relatif aux
nouvelles écoles supérieures du
professeur à et de l'éducation sp en
précisant que ces dernières peuvent par
auront également les futurs enseignants
et personnels d'éducation à la promotion
de la santé des élèves au travers de la
vaccination une formation la santé de
dès l'école non dans le cadre d'un cours
magistral la ministre a d'ailleurs
rappelé tout à l'heure sur d'autres
thèmes mais sur la forme la plus
participative collective possible
permettant aux élèves de comprendre
l'intérêt et l'importance de la
vaccination apparaît aujourd'hui comme
un moyen important de la lutte contre la
désinformation
surtout à l'heure où internet fait et
défait les rumeurs participants ainsi
vous le savez bien à faire disons ou à
décrédibiliser la politique vaccinale et
a contesté le bien fondé de la
vaccination
par cet amendement nous souhaitons nous
assurer que la formation des enseignants
intègre cette dimension d'éducation à la
santé à la prévention et aux vaccins
ainsi formés aux enjeux la vaccination
les futurs professeurs sont à mesure de
faire une présentation objective des
intérêts que la vaccination présentent
pour la santé des élèves
et de la nécessité de faire les rappels
vaccinant je vous remercie
merci monsieur la base et madame le
rapporteur
la commission comprend les
préoccupations qui sont les vôtres de
celle d' de fer qui une meilleure
couverture vaccinale néanmoins elle émis
un avis défavorable parce que la
modification du code de l'éducation
relative aux écoles supérieures du
professorat de l'éducation si certes en
effet on peut y introduire des
déformations en promotion de santé le
limiter aux seuls effets de la
vaccination serait serait très réducteur
c'est quand même difficile de toucher au
code de l'éducation
ainsi dans le cadre de la loi santé et
d'autre part même si on souhaite en
effet que les enseignants puissent
connaître en effet les bienfaits de la
vaccination et la nécessité de la
vaccination a été rappelle vaccinaux ça
reste quand même un conseil une décision
qui doit revenir aux professions
médicales
merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame le ministre donne un avis
défavorable monsieur la baiser à cet
amendement et je vais vous dire d'abord
que effectivement les personnels de
santé de l'éducation nationale relève du
ministère de l'éducation nationale de
même que la médecine du travail relève
du ministère du travail et donc il y a
là un principe on peut le discuter on
peut le regretter on peut vouloir
l'amendé mais il est là et donc c'est la
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
aujourd'hui a
autorité sur ces personnels donc je dis
très sincèrement que je ne vois pas
comment je peux moi ici
interférer avec ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'organisation dans notre pays mais au
demeurant je me suis quand même
renseigné auprès du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et il se trouve
que dans les écoles supérieures du
professeur à et de l'éducation et bien
la politique
de fait la promotion à la santé et
l'importance de la vaccination sont font
partie intégrante de la formation qui
est aujourd'hui dispensés donc il me
semble que votre demande est satisfaite
donc avis défavorable merci madame le
ministre
pour explication de vote monsieur la
base et oui j'ai moins d'assurance
maintenant que l'amendement précédent
vous l'avez compris aussi je n'ai pas
créé décidant à l'heure nous sommes ce
que nous avons eu le débat je veux
simplement rappeler à notre ministre ce
soir c'est qu'au moment du débat sur la
loi de refondation de l'école quand je
vais présenter cet amendement puisque
il c'était au moment où nous avions
rédigé ce rapport le ministre de
l'époque m'avait dit c'est très bien
mais attendez la loi santé qui viennent
avant quelques
dans quelques années pour tous oui voilà
elle a aidé vie pour pouvoir désormais
présentés notamment de vente d'envoyer
valable la ministre que j'ai de la suite
dans les idées mais je vais retirer mon
amendement
bien il a été retiré
merci
deux amendements identiques le à
l'article 2 bis à madame cohen 1 697 à
monsieur watrin pardon oui messieurs
président nous demandons par cet
amendement le rétablissement de
l'article 12 bis a supprimé par la
commission des affaires sociales qui
vise à garantir l'accès des étudiantes
et des étudiants au centre de santé
universitaire cet article 1 sert à
l'assemblée nationale vise à reconnaître
la possibilité
pour les services universitaires et
interuniversitaire de médecine
préventive et de promotion de la santé
agréés comme son de santé de contribuer
à l'accès aux soins de premier recours
la commission estimait que l'article 63
23 1 du code de la santé publique
reconnaissait déjà aux structures
sanitaires de proximité la possibilité
de dispenser des soins de premier
recours si les centres de santé sont des
structures sanitaires de proximité
dispensant principalement des soins de
premier recours les services
universitaire et interuniversitaire de
médecine préventive et de promotion de
la santé ne sont pas reconnus comme des
structures sanitaires de proximité
nous estimons donc nécessaire d'ouvrir
la même reconnaissance au service de
médecine de prévention de promotion de
la santé qui sont agréés centres de
santé
merci monsieur watrin
madame archambault pour un amendement
identique mais maintenant que monsieur
battra très bien défendu merci
madame leurs rapporteurs
alors donc ces deux amendements visent à
rétablir l'article 2 bis à nous l'avions
supprimé puisque
il tendait à
compléter le code de l'éducation afin de
préciser que les services universitaires
interuniversitaire de médecine
préventive et promotion de la santé les
sims qui s'appelle différemment je crois
maintenant lorsqu ils dispensent des
soins en tant que centre de santé ins et
bien lorsqu'ils sont autorisées à
dispenser des soins en sang en tant que
centre de santé contribuent à l'accès
aux soins de premier recours mais c'est
déjà la définition des centres de santé
en tant que centre santé les sims
constitue contribuer aux soins de
premier recours car les centres de santé
sont précisément définis comme des
structures sanitaires de proximité
dispensant principalement des soins de
premier recours articles l 63 23 tirs 1
du code de la santé publique il n'a pas
semblé à la commission qu'il était il
est utile de leur préciser dans la loi
c'était tout à fait toute logique et
nous avons donc maintenu la volonté de
supprimer cet article des madame le
rapporteur madame la ministre avis
favorable à cet amendement puisque
c'étaient des dispositions qui ont été
discutées à l'assemblée nationale c'est
une mesure qui est de nature à favoriser
l'accès aux soins et la promotion de la
santé la prise en charge de la santé des
étudiants mais j'insiste pas des
étudiants exclusivement puisque vous le
savez la loi interdit de réserver des
centres de santé à des catégories
particulières de population et donc y
compris un centre universitaire devenu
centre de santé doit pouvoir accueillir
par exemple la retraitée
merci madame la ministre
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par la commission
sur ces deux amendements identiques le
697 et le 1032 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
que l'avis du gouvernement est favorable
et que nous allons procéder au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 de notre règlement
voici le résultat donc de ce scrutin sur
les amendements 697 et 1032 nombre de
votants 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
344 pour l'adoption 156 contre
l'adoption
188 le sénat n'a pas adopté et l'article
de bissa reste supprimer
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance nous avons examiné je crois
soixante trois amendements au cours de
la journée il en risque il reste
il reste
madame la rapporteure 1053 à examiner si
on ce texte voilà vous êtes donc pu
suivre la suite de l'examen du projet de
loi de modernisation du système de santé
en particulier l'article 2 qui vise à
soutenir les jeunes pour l'égalité des
chances en matière de santé un article
qui n'a pas été votée vous pouvez revoir
bien sûr ce programme sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne
journée sur notre antenne